we're in the in a kind of a culture of
victimhood where victimhood makes you
powerful so I don't understand why they
don't realize that victimizing Trump is
going to make them more powerful or seem
more powerful he's like relegated
himself to the corner of the internet on
his own social network barely anyone
hears from him he's it's like radio
sounds people are talking about DeSantis
and yet this liberal media company these
people are still bringing him into the
spotlight the same dumb thing they did
in 2016 and got him elected Hillary
Clinton got him elected because all she
did was talk about them there's some
people who think that this is also
intentional to boost him because they
would rather face him in a general I
tend to disagree with that I think that
they're genuinely still so hung up on
Trump and they're still so incensed by
him and they're still so fearful of the
idea of populism rising in America that
they're willing to do anything to take
him down because of the idea he
represents and I think that's what they
really fear you know